- Oh, hi, I'm sorry, they
didn't have any booths.
- It's okay, don't worry about it.
- I tried to make a space for you,
I didn't know how high your chair was.
- It's all good.
- You need some help?
- No, I'm fine, I got it.
- I can, like, lift you.
- Danielle, right?
Yo, it's nice to finally
meet you in person.
- Oh, I can push myself.
- All right, damn, I
was trying to be nice.
- This one's on the house.
You're so brave.
- Thanks.
- So, are you hungry?
- Yeah, I heard this place has
really good mac and cheese.
- Yeah, so what happened to your feet?
- As soon as I saw on your profile
that you're an amputee,
I had to message you.
Do you know what a devotee is?
- Yeah.
- Okay, girl, I've got
the perfect guy for you.
He just started at my job,
and he's in a wheelchair.
- Okay, and like, what else?
Like, tell me about him.
- Uh.
- He sounds fascinating.
- Uh, excuse me, why
are you parking there?
Do you see this is handicapped, huh?
- Uh, sorry, man.
- Too bad, man, don't say sorry to me,
say sorry to her.
- My last girlfriend,
she was missing an arm,
but that wasn't exactly what
I was looking for, you know?
- How do you think she feels?
She has to come over here,
and she sees a perfectly fine,
oh hey, just dancing out of his car,
parked in the handicapped, huh?
I'm gonna put you
everywhere, you know what?
I'm gonna expose you right now.
Worldstar, Snapchat,
everything, I got it all.
This is our first date.
I'm trying to impress her,
and she gotta come over
here and see this (bleep).
- Sorry.
- It's fine, just don't park there again.
- I think anybody would give up their feet
to get a beautiful smile like yours.
- This is very embarrassing, people!
They have the best plantains in LA.
- Really, you can't get
good plantains anywhere.
- Anywhere, they deep fry it in duck fat.
- Is there another entrance?
- You know what, I don't
even like this place.
It only has like four stars in Yelp.
- You go, girl.
- Okay, how does sex work for you?
- You know, you're
funny, you're beautiful.
And the fact that you don't
have either of your feet
just really does it for me.
- Yeah, like, when you
roll over a bumpy road,
is that like a vibrator,
do you come that way?
- That makes no sense.
- Have you ever had sex in your chair?
- I can't believe you've been going out
with so many creeps.
- Girl, and like you don't date creeps?
- I guess there was that one guy
that wouldn't stop
trying to touch my hair.
- To (bleep)-boys, losers, and weirdos.
- Salud.
- You should have sex in your chair.